Remember when Inside the Magic Schoolbus shrank
down and flew into Arnold?
Yeah, science is actually doing that.
THE FUTURE IS NOW.
Giant feats of engineering like space vehicles,
dams, skyscrapers and massive airplanes are
complex, to be sure… but at least the engineers
working on them can SEE what they're working
on.
Imagine engineering a pump which is only a
single molecule in size.
Yeah.
It's REALLY HARD, but a team from Northwestern
University did it earlier this year.
In nature, molecules are constantly moving
around in our bodies, transporting energy,
oxygen, and even information from one place
to another; this molecular pump is a rudimentary
synthetic copy of something nature does all
the time.
This pump uses a dumbbell-shaped molecule,
and a set of positively charged molecular
rings.
Sort of like two magnets repelling each other,
the rings provide tiny amounts of energy that
the synthetic molecule can use to make the
pump ratchet at a predictable rate!
The problem with nanotechnology, has always
been powering itty-bitty things; and realizing
they can harvest energy from nano-scale rings
is enough is pretty huge… or… small…
I mean…
They're hoping if they can improve the tech
and capture MORE rings they'd have enough
energy to power artificial muscles, or even
whole nanomachines!
The development of nanotechnology has been
steadily climbing over the last 40 years and
with leaps like this, things are starting
to get crazy.
In 2004, scientists at New York University
created a nanobot that bipedally "walks" on
legs 10 nanometers long by adding a molecule
called psoralen found in the seeds of celery,
parsley, citrus fruits and the common fig.
A few years later, a study on the future of
nanomaterials said we're only 10 to 20 years
from a nanosized factory.
This psoralen molecule lets the nanobot "walk"
along a DNA strand; the researchers envision
this as the beginnings of a nanobot conveyor
belt for nanoassembly… think about the coolness
of a nano-sized car factory… assembling
nanobots for any imaginable purpose.
The NIH says nanocomputers and nanobots could
revolutionize the medical industry by creating
nanobots which could mechanically reverse
plaque buildup in arteries, or prepare tissues
for cryonic storage, repair spinal damage,
rewrite individual bases in our DNA, improve
the efficiency of our cells, or map the complicated
connections of the mammalian brain.
Things are moving real fast in this y'all.
In 1998, researchers (hypothetically) designed
a red blood cell 200 times more efficient
than our own.
It was, in essence, an atomic-sized oxygen
tank that could fill up in the lungs and distribute
oxygen to the tissues way better than our
own cells can.
If that sounds far fetched, take this for
a spin.
Papers in the journal ACS Nano and Physics
Today (among many others) from the last couple
of years use what researchers are calling
"DNA origami," to carry medication directly
to cancer cells.
DNA origami is essentially a nano-engineered
"barrel" that can carry drugs or information
to a specific place, and release it!
Nanotechnology is getting better and better
and better…You know what else is getting
better?
Toyota!
Toyota has been doing some tinkering of their
own with the TRD line of Toyota Trucks.
Enhanced to rule the off-road!